el presidente turco recep tayyp erdogán
ha dejado muy claro el porqué de su
negativa a finlandia y abc de poder
entrar en la otan y ha asegurado que es
porque los dos países son casas y
huéspedes de grupos terroristas no ha
firmado el presidente turco cuáles son
esos grupos pero se entiende que se
refiere sobre todo a dos son una
cofradía ante el clérigo fécula gülen
exiliado desde los años 90 en eeuu y el
partido de los trabajadores del
kurdistán pkk
por parte es la cofradía de fécula gülen
es acusada de ser la que estuvo detrás
del intento de golpe de estado que
fracasó en julio de 2016 en turquía y
después del cual hubo una purga inmensa
dentro de la administración de turquía
muchos de sus miembros huyeron de
turquía y se fueron a europa donde la
justicia europea les mantiene asegurando
que si fuesen deportados de vuelta a
turquía como pide turquía a recibir en
un juicio justo por lo tanto se les
permite que tengan asilo político en
europa también en los países
escandinavos también pasa algo parecido
con los miembros del pkk que están en
europa esta guerrilla lleva en guerra
con el estado turco desde la década de
los 80 y por esta guerra tanto a manos
del estado de turquía como
la guerrilla del pkk han muerto cerca de
40 a 45 mil personas la mayoría de los
cuales son a civiles se entiende según
muchos expertos que la decisión de
erdogán de por el momento no permitir la
entrada de suecia y finlandia la otan es
para intentar ganar algo de eeuu que ha
sido uno de los países que se ha apoyado
más en el pkk en su filial siria para
luchar contra el estado sádico las siete
que son una final siria del pkk son las
que fueron la punta de lanza de eeuu en
la lucha contra el estado islámico que
terminó hace algo más de tres años con
esta forma podría turquía podría
intentar estar ganándose un poco de
razón política para continuar sus
operaciones militares contra el grupo
tanto dentro de territorio turco como
también como ocurren actualmente en irak
y también después como ya han pasado
anteriormente en el norte de siria